michel larive bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous pour répondre à nos
questions alors on l'a vu après theresa
may en 2018 et vladimir poutine l'an
dernier c'est au tour bangala merkel
d'être invité par emmanuel macron au
fort de brégançon pourquoi choisir ce
lieu selon vous c'est plutôt symbolique
l'invité sûrement les gens qu'il veut
mettre en lumière sur le moment où yves
le cher et puis pourquoi pas il ya lee a
de toute manière des discussions à avoir
avec la martelle sur l'europe mais c'est
parce que les discussions doivent avoir
lieu aussi avec le reste de l'europe
surtout sur les dossiers chauds qui ont
été quand été discutée entre ses deux
interlocuteurs notamment l'international
mais vous avez oublié aussi d'europe sur
le plan de relance qui n'est que de 750
milliards d'euros
alors ce que le parlement avait demandé
2 milliards d'euros et le punisher le
breton lui demandait au moins 1600
milliards d'aud donc la villa va se
passer cet
cette rentrée postes coïncide avec ce
plan de relance de 750 milliards d'euros
si l'on veut ce n'est pas assez non mais
écoutez je viens vous dire que le
parlement devant des 2 milliards d'euros
donc c'est bien loin de là métier c'est
presque le tiers et le commissaire le
breton lui demander 1600 milliards
d'euros donc ça veut dire qu'il est très
clairement insuffisant et qui va y avoir
des choix
et puis en plus il est conditionné à
quelque chose qui est aberrant
complètement aberrant c'est le retour à
l'équilibré budgétaire
nous sommes dans une crise sanitaire qui
induit utilisé comme rick grave est
cette crise économique grave creuse les
déficits revenir à un équilibre
économique quasi utopique nous nous
proposons de mettre la tête dans un
processus perpétuel et de la rembourser
sur
comme aeternam avec les taux d'intérêt
qui vaut bien et donc elle s'éteindra
d'elle-même
c'est une solution par ce retour à
l'équilibré avec le processus de 3%
c'est impossible le monde d'allah traîne
pourra jamais être comme le monde avant
michel larive on l'a vu çà a été dé
retrouver ses chaleureuses entre la
chancelière allemande et et le chef de
l'état français il ya eu comme vous
l'avez dit à l'instant plusieurs
dossiers brûlants de l'actualité est ce
que cette rencontre elle a mis en
lumière les convergences entre les deux
pays européens selon vous écouter le
rock on a vu pendant la crise un critère
l'europe n'était pas du tout mais alors
pas du tout un chacun tiré de son côté
deux pays attendait enfin la solidarité
européenne qu'il n'est pas venu et donc
c'est un signal que je pense que demain
coin grammaire qu'elles ont voulu donner
de jeu couple franco allemand moteur de
l'europe pour essayer de rendre une
nouvelle cohésion à l'europe
parce que là qui sont invités à passer
par là et l europe a montré c'est plus
que ses faiblesses ses divergences et
des chats non solidité y aller on est
gros sujet de cette rencontre c'est la
situation en biélorussie et anyama kron
a proposé une médiation européenne selon
vous en quoi cela consisterait je sais
pas en quoi consiste la médiation
européenne de monsieur mac ont justement
je vous le savez dans l'opposition donc
pas dans les serres de décision du
gouvernement mais en tout cas c'est au
peuple là comme on manie comme ailleurs
c'est au peuple de se décider de sa
destinée
alors il y à un mouvement en biélorussie
indéniable il c'est le peuple qu'il faut
écouter et ne pas vouloir comme des fois
ailleurs aller plus loin que ce qu'il
faudrait est entré dans une espèce
d'ingérence c'est au peuple de décider
de sa destinée donc en bio en
biélorussie c'est lui qui tu verras
comment les choses se poursuivront et
l'europe doit-elle doit être attentive à
accompagner les peuples et pas les
dirigeants merci à michel larive d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes député la france en soumises
de l'ariège